in here who opened those doors why was
security called off what in the world
was going on here with Ray Epps there's
a lot of questions I think those
questions deserve to be answered and the
January 6th commission was is not
answering them the video of them opening
the doors you're talking about the
magnetic doors yeah it's from inside the
building and there's people outside
yelling and then someone walks up to the
magnetic door sealed doors they're
barred shut they look back and like
point up at someone and then the doors
are magnetically unlocked and opened and
all these people start pouring in who
opened the door who verified the door
being able to push the I want to know
too it's crazy video because someone
look for all we know someone broke into
the security booth and hit the button
maybe okay let's let's get that video
released so we can figure out what's
going on I think that would have been a
talking point by the corporate media and
the Democrats look at these they had
Insider side knowledge they knew what
their door they did they ran dry drills
they they knew where the button was we
haven't had any of that but they would
have sensationalized it to the highest
degree that they could